CONTINUES NOW ON "THE LEAD" WITH
JAKE TAPPER.
>> THIS IS CNN BREAKING NEWS.
>> WELCOME TO "THE LEAD."
I'M DANA BASH IN FOR JAKE
TAPPER.
WE CONTINUE WITH THE BREAKING
NEWS, A FEDERAL COURT IN FLORIDA
UNSEALED THE WARRANT THAT
INVESTIGATORS USED TO SEARCH THE
HOME OF FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THE WARRANT CITES THREE LAWS,
OBSTRUCTION, REMOVING OF
GOVERNMENT RECORDS, AND THE
ESPIONAGE ACT.
THE WARRANT LISTED THE
CLASSIFICATION OF DOCUMENTS THAT
WERE SEIZED FROM MAR-A-LAGO ON
MONDAY, INCLUDING FOUR SETS OF
TOP SECRET DOCUMENTS, THREE SETS
OF SECRET DOCUMENTS, THREE SETS
OF CONFIDENTIAL DOCUMENTS.
AND VARIOUS DOCUMENTS WERE
MARKED AS TOP SECRET SENSITIVE
COMPARTMENTALIZED INFORMATION.
THIS WOULD BE MATERIAL SO
SENSITIVE THAT THE U.S. GOES TO
EXCRUCIATING EFFORTS TO CONCEAL
IT.
ONLY PEOPLE WITH TOP CLEARANCE
CAN READ THEM, AND THEY HAVE TO
DO IT IN A SCIF.
THESE SCIFs REQUIRE A SPECIAL
LOCK AND HAVE RE-ENFORCED WALLS
AND ELECTRONIC METHODS TO
PREVENT SPYING.
I'M GOING TO GO TO KATELYN
POLANTZ.
YOU HAVE THE WARRANTS.
WHAT ELSE ARE WE LEARNING?
>> THERE'S MORE INFORMATION IN
HERE THAN WE COULD HAVE EXPECTED
YESTERDAY.
THERE IS THREE PAGES THAT REALLY
LAY OUT EXACTLY WHAT WAS SEIZED
FROM THE PROPERTY OF THE FORMER
PRESIDENT AT MAR-A-LAGO, THE
BEACH CLUB THAT IS ALSO HIS
HOME.
AND IS NOT A SECURED FACILITY IN
THE WAY THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SETS UP SECURED
FACILITIES AT THIS TIME.
AND THIS LIST, IT WALKS THROUGH,
THERE ARE 33 ITEMS HERE THAT
WERE SEIZED AS FAR AS THIS LIST
GOES.
MOST OF THEM ARE BOXES WITH
LABELS ON THEM.
ONE IS A LEATHER BOUND BOX OF
DOCUMENTS, WITHIN IT, IT APPEARS
THE WAY THIS IS WRITTEN THAT
THERE ARE VARIOUS CLASSIFIED
TSSCI DOCUMENTS THAT WERE TAKEN
OUT OF MAR-A-LAGO OR AT LEAST
THEY WERE LABELED AS SUCH.
TSSCI IS THAT VERY HIGH LEVEL OF
CLASSIFICATION IN THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT, TOP SECRET,
SENSITIVE COMPARTMENTED
INFORMATION.
IT REALLY IS THE SORT OF
INFORMATION THAT IS EXTREMELY
PROTECTED AND ONLY CERTAIN
PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO ACCESS IT.
THIS IS WHAT IS UNDER
INVESTIGATION.
NOT NECESSARILY THE CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION BUT JUST THE IDEA
THAT THINGS THAT COULD HURT THE
NATIONAL DEFENSE, THAT COULD
HURT THE UNITED STATES, WERE
BEING KEPT IN AN UNSECURE
LOCATION, AND WHEN WE LOOK ALSO
AT WHAT WAS BEING SEARCHED, HOW
THE FEDERAL AUTHORITIES WOULD
HAVE BEEN DOING THEIR JOB, WE
CAN SEE THAT THEY WERE GIVEN
PRETTY BROAD DIRECTION AS TO
WHERE THEY WERE TO GO TO LOOK.
THEY WERE TO LOOK IN THE OFFICE
OF THE FORMER PRESIDENT, IN
AREAS IN OTHER ROOMS BEING USED
BY THE FORMER PRESIDENT WHERE
THERE COULD BE DOCUMENTS KEPT
THAT WOULD BE UNSECURED.
THINGS THEY NEEDED TO REALLY GET
OUT OF THAT PLACE.
AND THEN THE OTHER THING THAT IS
OF INTEREST HERE IS THAT WHEN
THIS WAS -- THIS RECEIPT WAS
SIGNED AND HANDED OVER AS THE
FBI WOULD HAVE BEEN LEAVING, WE
SEE A TIME STAMP OF 6:19 P.M.
THAT REALLY DOES CONFIRM THE FBI
WORKED FOR MOST OF THE DAY TO
TRY AND TAKE THESE THINGS OFF OF
THE PREMISES AND GET THEM BACK
INTO A SECURE HANDS.
>> SO INTERESTING.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT.
I WANT TO BRING IN OUR CNN
SENIOR JUSTICE CORRESPONDENT,
EVAN PEREZ.
SO EVAN, YOU SAID SOMETHING
INTERESTING THAT I CALLED YOU
ABOUT BECAUSE I SAID, WHAT?
THIS IS REALLY CRITICAL.
AND IT'S ABOUT THE THREE LAWS
THAT ARE CITED IN THIS SEARCH
WARRANT.
YOU HEAR THE FORMER PRESIDENT OR
SEE HIM IN HIS STATEMENTS TODAY
SAYING I DIDN'T TAKE ANY
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
BUT WHAT YOUR REPORTING IS
READING THESE LAWS IS THAT'S NOT
NECESSARILY RELEVANT.
CAN YOU EXPLAIN THAT?
>> YEAH, SO THE THREE LAWS, I'LL
READ YOU THE THREE FEDERAL
CODES, ONE IS 793.
THAT'S KNOWN AS THE ESPIONAGE
ACT, GATHERING, TRANSMITTING OR
LOSING DEFENSE INFORMATION.
CODE 1519, THIS IS DESTRUCTION,
ALTERATION, FALSIFICATION OF
RECORDS.
IN FEDERAL INVESTIGATION.
THIS IS AN OBSTRUCTION STATUTE,
AND THEN THERE'S 2071, WHICH IS
CONCEALMENT, MUTILATION OF
FEDERAL DOCUMENTS.
WHAT'S INTERESTING ABOUT
ESPECIALLY IF YOU LOOK AT 793,
WHICH IS THE ESPIONAGE ACT, THE
NATIONAL DEFENSE INFORMATION.
IT DOESN'T REALLY TURN ON
WHETHER THE ITEMS ARE
DECLASSIFIED.
IT DOESN'T TURN ON WHETHER YOU
HAVE AUTHORITY TO POSSESS THESE
DOCUMENTS.
SO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT,
ACCORDING TO THIS DOCUMENT, THE
PROSECUTORS AT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT ARE INVESTIGATING
POSSIBLE CRIMES.
THIS IS THE PROOF THEY GAVE TO A
FEDERAL JUDGE TO SAY WE BELIEVE
AT MAR-A-LAGO THERE WERE
CRIMES -- EVIDENCE OF THESE
CRIMES.
WHAT'S IMPORTANT ABOUT THIS IS
THAT THEY'RE USING SPECIFIC LAWS
THAT COULD INOCULATE THEIR
INVESTIGATION FROM WHAT WE
EXPECT TO BE THE SURE FIRE
DONALD TRUMP DEFENSE, WHICH IS I
DECLASSIFIED EVERYTHING.
BY SAYING SO, I AUTOMATICALLY
DECLASSIFIED THINGS.
OF COURSE, WE KNOW IT'S A LITTLE
MORE COMPLICATED THAN THAT, BUT
THAT'S WHERE WE KNOW DONALD
TRUMP IS GOING TO GO.
WE CAN ALREADY SEE THAT IN SOME
OF HIS DEFENSES.
ONE OTHER THING I THINK THAT
STOOD OUT TO ME FROM THIS
DOCUMENT REAL QUICK, DANA, IS
THE DOCUMENT SAYS THAT THE JUDGE
IS AUTHORIZING THE FBI TO SHOW
UP ANYTIME FROM 6:00 A.M. TO
10:00 P.M.
WE KNOW THAT THE FBI SHOWED UP
AROUND 10:00 A.M.
IT GIVES YOU A SENSE OF THE
DEFERENCE THEY WERE GIVING TO
THE FORMER PRESIDENT FOR THE
OFFICE THAT HE HELD.
YOU KNOW, THEY COULD HAVE GONE
IN THERE WITH THEIR FBI JACKETS.
THEY CAME IN WITH SUITS AND
TIES.
THEY CAME AROUND 10:00 A.M.
THEY WERE TRYING TO NOT MAKE
THIS A SPECTACLE.
HE IS THE ONE THAT WENT OUT
RIGHT AFTER THE FBI LEFT THE
PREMISES AND BLASTED OUT HIS
STATEMENT AND HAS CREATED A
SPECTACLE OF WHAT HAPPENED HERE.
>> EVAN, THAT'S VERY INTERESTING
AND AN IMPORTANT POINT BECAUSE
NOW WE DO HAVE THESE TIME
STAMPS.
BACK TO YOUR ORIGINAL POINT, IF
THE FORMER PRESIDENT DIDN'T
NECESSARILY BREAK THE LAW, JUST
TO USE LAYMAN'S TERMS, BECAUSE
OF OR THIS WASN'T PRECIPITATED
BECAUSE OF HIS POSSESSION OF ANY
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION, WHAT
WOULD BE THE POTENTIAL AREA
WHERE HE DID BREAK THE LAW?
>> WELL, WHAT THIS MEANS IS THAT
IT DOESN'T MATTER THAT IT WAS
CLASSIFIED OR NOT.
WHAT THEY'RE TRYING TO SAY, YOU
KNOW, BY PRESENTING THESE
STATUTES AS THE REASON FOR DOING
THIS SEARCH, WHAT THE
PROSECUTORS ARE DOING IS SAYING
THAT THIS WAS A VIOLATION OF THE
LAW SIMPLY BECAUSE BY PUTTING
THESE DOCUMENTS, WHICH COULD
HARM THE UNITED STATES.
THESE ARE NATIONAL DEFENSE
INFORMATION DOCUMENTS THAT YOU
ARE VIOLATING THE LAW.
SO YOU COULD VIOLATE THE LAW
EVEN IF YOU AS FORMER PRESIDENT
DECLASSIFIED THEM.
WHICH IS I THINK WHAT HE'S GOING
TO ARGUE.
SO WHAT THIS MEANS IS YOU CAN
BREAK THE LAW EVEN IF DONALD
TRUMP HAS ALREADY SAID I HEREBY
WAVE A WAND AND I HAVE
DECLASSIFIED THINGS.
>> SUCH IMPORTANT CONTEXT AND
REPORTING.
THANKS, AS ALWAYS.
>> I WANT TO BRING IN TOM
DUPREE, WHO WAS THE NUMBER TWO
IN THE DOJ CIVIL DIVISION UNDER
GEORGE W. BUSH, AND ALSO KIM
WEHLE, WHO SERVED AS AN
ASSISTANT U.S. ATTORNEY.
TOM, YOU HAVE READ THE WARRANT.
YOU HEARD EVAN'S REPORTING AND
KATELYN'S AS WELL.
THESE THREE LAWS, OBSTRUCTION,
REMOVING OF GOVERNMENT RECORDS,
THE ESPIONAGE ACT.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF IT.
>> THE BIG TICKET ONE IS THE
ESPIONAGE ACT.
THAT EXPLAINS WHAT'S BEEN GOING
ON BEHIND THE SCENES OF THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT, THAT WHAT
THIS WARRANT WE SEE TODAY
CONFIRMS IS THAT THIS IS JUST
NOT A GARDEN VARIETY DISPUTE
ABOUT ARCHIVING.
IT'S NOT A TICKY TACK DISPUTE
ABOUT WHERE PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS
ARE STORED.
RATHER, THIS REALLY GOES TO THE
HEART OF THE UNITED STATES
NATIONAL SECURITY.
IT'S AN ESPIONAGE ACT POTENTIAL
CHARGE.
AND I THINK WHAT HAPPENED AT DOJ
WAS THEY SIMPLY SAID THAT THESE
DOCUMENTS THAT THE PRESIDENT IS
REFUSING TO TURN BACK OVER TO
THE GOVERNMENT ARE NOT MEMENTOS,
SOUVENIRS OF HIS TIME IN OFFICE.
RATHER, THEY ARE DOCUMENTS THAT
HAVE A DIRECT MATERIAL RELEVANCE
TO THE NATIONAL SECURITY OF THE
UNITED STATES.
THAT'S WHY WE NEED THEM BACK,
AND THAT'S WHY IT WAS
APPROPRIATE TO EXECUTE A WARRANT
ON MAR-A-LAGO.
>> KIM, WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> WELL, DANA, OF COURSE, I HAVE
JUST BEEN ABLE TO READ THE
WARRANT AND LOOK AT THESE
STATUTES, BUT THERE ARE A COUPLE
THINGS THAT JUMP OUT TO ME.
ONE IS THE ESPIONAGE ACT IS
REALLY LONG.
THERE'S A PART OF IT THAT SAYS
AUTHORIZED USERS CANNOT SHARE
THIS INFORMATION, WHETHER HE'S
AUTHORIZED OR NOT, I THINK IS
UNCLEAR UNLESS HE SOMEHOW WAVED
HIS MAGIC WAND AND DECLASSIFIED
IT, HE DID NOT HAVE ANY LEGAL
RIGHT TO HAVE THIS.
I THINK IT'S POSSIBLE ANOTHER
PROVISION OF THAT ACT WOULD
APPLY.
THE WARRANT, IT DOESN'T SAY
WHICH SUBSECTION.
THE OTHER PROVISIONS APPLY IF
THERE'S INTENT TO SHARE
INFORMATION IN ORDER TO INJURE
THE UNITED STATES OR TO
ADVANTAGE FOREIGN NATIONS.
I THINK THAT'S QUITE
INTERESTING.
THE OBSTRUCTION STATUTE, ALSO
VERY INTERESTING BECAUSE IT'S
NOT JUST OBSTRUCTION BY HAVING
THESE THINGS.
IT'S, YOU ARE DESTROYING OR
CONCEALING DOCUMENTS IN ORDER TO
OBSTRUCT ANOTHER INVESTIGATION.
SO MY QUESTION WOULD BE, WHAT --
WAS THERE PROBABLE CAUSE TO
BELIEVE IS THE OTHER
INVESTIGATION THAT THESE
DOCUMENTS IN MAR-A-LAGO WERE
ALLEGEDLY POTENTIALLY THERE TO
OBSTRUCT.
AND THEN OF COURSE, THE LAST ONE
IS MORE, YOU JUST CAN'T HAVE --
YOU CAN'T DESTROY OR CONCEAL
THESE KINDS OF DOCUMENTS.
SO THIS IS, YOU KNOW, THIS IS
POTENTIALLY DECADES IN PRISON.
LAST POINT I WANTED TO MAKE IS,
IT'S UNCLEAR WHOSE INTENT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE.
OF COURSE, DONALD TRUMP IS THE
RESIDENT AT MAR-A-LAGO, THE
OWNER.
BUT IT'S UNCLEAR FROM THE
WARRANT IF THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT
DO